the cardinals turn to the lefty kwang
hun kim kk gets the call tonight yeah
they're gonna need him tonight but you
know what everyone's gonna need everyone
tonight they just got to start playing a
little bit better baseball here's a
strike three call man
kim gets a breaking ball in there he
gets a call strike
nice play tommy edmond
no throw back and he does get the lead
man and takes a hit away he was just a
normal double play depth wasn't taking
away the middle so able to get over
there and
make the nice pick and nice feed to his
shortstop
ground ball to sosa and a scoreless
first headache
will crow
he array
flighted a bit just because of the one
tough start at kansas city where he gave
up eight and four innings pitched well
last couple times out dylan carlson the
22 year old center fielder switch hitter
breaking ball looped out to left there's
ben gamel to retire it for the first out
lifted to right coming on evans he's
there
and the cardinals strand a couple here's
large newt barb
newt barr base hitting to right well
just much the bat path i love this it's
not up it's not down it's not all over
the place it's
really smooth and really straight to the
point
newt barr was running diving stock and
no play
putting runners in motion one ball and
two strikes on kim
and he's hit by the pitch
oh man he's got a little smile
thankfully he says he's all right so the
bases will be loaded the 2-1
carlson ground ball right side they'll
get the lead man it's dropped but
they're gonna say that is it out and run
does score that is new bar and it's one
nothing saint louis so the criminals do
get a run and they grab an early lead
one-nothing on the ground out by dylan
carlson
and the liner to center and there he is
brian reynolds making another
outstanding defensive play he is so good
at that one in particular straight in
front of him thinking liner he is so
good at not only the jump but timing the
dive hurts down one nothing men at the
corners
with one out and key brian hayes singled
last time up
and this is going to drop into center
field key brian hayes
has tied the game at one he's so good at
staying inside and through that fastball
in and on the hands the pirates have the
table set here with the bases loaded and
jacob stallings up
and a little stumble for stallings out
of the box but that's okay he's going to
get a run hole and the pirates take a
2-1 lead
and a line drive toward right field but
that is caught
oh it's dropped by newt barr he had it
and then dropped it
and evans will be caught between first
and second
but the pirates will score two out of it
mootbar came sliding in and dropped it
and the pirates lead 4-1 nolan oronato
hitting at 264 has 14 home runs 48 rbis
arenado hits it down the left field line
gone
career home run number 250.
he jumped on it
his 15th home run of 2021
number 250 of his career
here is yadier molina
and yani hits it down the left field
line
a historic hit for yadier molina he
passes johnny bench
for eighth place in career hits by a
catcher
[Applause]
2049
for yadier molina
lars newt barr singled and scored in the
second
newt bar base head and the right he's
two for two
and he comes through with a two out hit
to score yadier molina and that makes it
four to three and they're saying nude
here at the ballpark
one out for dylan carlson
and carlson with a fly ball out to deep
left it's at the whoa god
opposite field home run
dylan carlson his first at home in 2021
and he's tied it up for four
that is what i'm talking about
it's been a while since he's hit a ball
that hard
the other way
with the short swing
nice job right here
it's a 4-4 game and jake woodford will
come in
broken bat
the tag applied no it'll throw it
and everybody's safe and now sosa is
hurt as he is down and calls time and he
is down and hurts
grabbing the back of his left leg that's
really awkward right there for him he
tried so hard to stay up
looks like he's going to stay in the
game
and now stallings
and a base hitting the left field
hayes will score
into third base
safe there
jacob stallings gives the pirates back
the lead in the fifth and that's uh huge
right there again taking advantage they
give you an extra out give you a man in
scoring position
take advantage of hayes moving on the
pitch
seventh inning coming up the three four
and five hitters against genesis cabrera
swaying in a mess and a strikeout for
cabrera so he's come in and gotten a
ground out and a pair of strikeouts and
retired three
2-2 pitch
fly ball into right newt barr is there
to make the catch
the 3-1 to him ground ball to third
arnato has it and that means evans is
out at first base arnotto throws him out
right-hander kyle crick coming out of
the bullpen for the pittsburgh pirates
grounded oh and off of crick
recovers throws and he gets him with a
play by kyle crick
oh
that wow was impressive you're so
worried because you're grabbing the ball
real quick and firing at the first
you're worried about him throwing it
away but
boy that that is a kick save and a
beauty and a great recovery
and throw
oh hop up stay in in play
and
yes
baby how about that inning great job
kyle crick from turtle creek yes sir
richard rodriguez
trying to save this one for will crow
oh another one that
oh
that's beautiful
raise the jolly roger in saint louis
and give the w to will crow
over the birds and the bucks win a nail
biter 5-4 in st louis tonight